they were scenes that
gripped the world's attention for 18
straight days
millions of egyptians demonstrated in
the streets and squares of the country's
cities
ultimately bringing about the end of
president hosni robotics 30-year rule
the protests began on january the 25th
with polls and social media platforms
for people to take to the streets
demanding freedom justice and bread
[Music]
those calls by unarmed civilians were
met with a type of police brutality that
was synonymous with the mubarak regime
consequently the demands and chance
shifted to a simple
and very clear one
the people demand the fall of the regime
on february the 11th it fell or so they
thought
mubarak stepped aside and the country's
military generals took charge
despite attempts by the army to maintain
power they were forced to allow the
country's first ever free and fair
parliamentary elections to take place
those were then followed by a vote for
the presidency which resulted in the
muslim brotherhood party's muhammad
mursi
becoming egypt's first ever
democratically elected president
throughout that time social and economic
instability became the norm
egyptians had begun experiencing
political freedom but living conditions
remained bad regular electricity outages
and the never-ending fuel shortage
crisis
led many to direct their opposition to
egypt's post-revolution president
this content continued to rise and in
2013
supported by the army and police another
mass protest took place
albeit far smaller in size and shorter
in duration than that of 2011.
the protesters said mursi had to go
because he failed to deliver on the
goals of the revolution
his supporters said it was the
counter-revolution that had been
sabotaging the morsi presidency
and was now behind the unrest it later
transpired that most of the crises were
in fact
manufactured and the violence which
rocked egypt's streets
had been encouraged by a deep state that
wanted to reverse the gains of the
january 25th revolution
the removal of morsi by a military coup
in 2013 installed army general abdel
fattah sisi as leader and ultimately
president
since al-sisi came to power egypt has
become the world's second largest
borrower from the imf
in 2014 the country had a foreign debt
of 46 billion dollars
today that figure is more than 125
billion
poverty levels in egypt have increased
drastically and more than 50 percent of
the country's revenue is spent
on trying to pay back its foreign debt
meanwhile al-sisi has found money to
build several huge new palaces
and buy a new presidential plane amongst
other things
actions that have enraged the egyptian
public the vast majority of which
lives on or below the poverty line
ten years on cairo's tahrir square is a
far cry from what it looked like
egypt is not the country those who
protested dreamed it would become
and for tens of millions of egyptians
they have little if any
freedom justice and bread
well jamal al-shayal joins us now live
in doha jamal
you reported on the arab spring closely
particularly egypt what can you remember
of that time
well it's very difficult to put into
words really what
we witnessed back then on january 25th
and the uh ensuing couple of weeks after
you know
when we talk about historical moments
moments that changed
the world definitely the 18 days
in tahrir and across egypt actually
were one of those things when you're
talking about millions of people coming
together
um with a very clear goal or demand
um you know waves upon waves of people
the way in which they
uh you know faced uh bullets with their
bare chests the way in which they united
regardless of their sex or religion
uh age gender all of these things they
were really uh
breathtaking scenes but what i remember
also as a journalist from that
perspective was just
how uh challenging it was to try and
uh essentially convey the message of
these people convey their
uh suffering convey their aspirations um
in you know short bite-sized two-minute
three-minute reports
reporting you're talking about 90
million egyptians
many of whom had lived 30 years under
this autocratic rule
and were finally essentially exploding
with a desire for a better way of life
so it was it was definitely historic
historic
assignment as you outlined in your
package there's been
even more political upheaval since then
how would you say the country is faring
now
well we just need to look at the facts
right so 10 years on you have
dozens of journalists behind bars
including one of our colleagues mahmoud
hussein who's been
imprisoned by the egyptian authorities
for some 500 days
you have poverty levels that are even
worse than they were
under mubarak so roughly 60 of the
egyptian population on
or below the poverty line um you have
egypt's
political standing in the region uh you
know
rolling back from being a leader to
being one
that has its policies dictated by many
states like the uae and others and
all of that basically means that those
who
revolted uh during the 2011 uprising
have seen not only that they
unfortunately for them
failed to achieve their demands and
their goals
but in fact the clock has been set back
in many respects
to worse than it was under mubarak but
that being said it doesn't mean that
they will have
they will admit that the revolution has
failed they've many people view it as
uh you know one round that they lost um
and
the proof in that is that there are
still mobilizations that take place in
sporadic protests
against the military against sisi's rule
that happen every so often in egypt that
many predict will culminate into
another round of mass uprisings in the
coming
months if not maybe a couple of years a
bleak outlook many thanks for that jamal
al-shail deforest live in doha